tous
[Musique]
le principal mythe dont découlent tous
les autres c'est le grand mythe de ce
qu'on appelle la défloration donc la
défloration fait ce serait d'imaginer
l'hymen comme une membrane clame
histoire de peau de tambour à l'entrée
de la vulve et que le jour de ce qu'on
appelle communément la première fois le
pénis viendrait perforé cette membrane
pour rentrer dans le vagin
donc c'est donc je sais absolument pas
comme ça que ça se passe c'est un mythe
totale puisque l'hymen donc
anatomiquement ce n'est pas une membrane
ce n'est pas un bouchon qui vient fermer
le vagin
mais au contraire c'est plutôt un petit
anneau qui est perforé donc de deux
principes de fait dès l'enfance qui va
se modifier en fait tout au long de
l'enfance et pendant l'adolescence et
qui permet de se manière de faire
s'écouler les règles donc voyez bien que
c'est pas imperméable
[Musique]
non l'hymen ne doit pas forcément
seigner lors des premiers rapports
sexuels
ça arrive dans environ 50% des cas donc
une chance sur deux il peut saigner un
petit peu parce que il a été déchiré à
un endroit à plusieurs endroits mais il
peut aussi simplement se distendre ou ne
pas bouger du tout
[Musique]
la douleur qui on peut ressentir lors
des premiers rapports sexuels ne vient
pas systématiquement de l'hymen ça peut
faire un petit peu mal mais la plupart
du temps cette douleur elle est plutôt
liée au stress et parfois la
précipitation des premières fois et
finalement ce stress cette précipitation
close un manque de lubrification chez la
femme et peut causer aussi d'une
contraction des muscles qui entoure le
vagin dont des muscles du périnée qui
peuvent tout à fait expliquer la douleur
ressentie si près dans la sexualité
cette entrée dans les rapports sexuels
ne se fait pas forcément par lumen ne se
fait pas forcément d'ailleurs par le
vagin
elle peut se faire de plein de manières
différentes il ya plein de sexualité
différente
il ya plein de manières de vivre ou de
ne pas vivre sa sexualité et ce sera
votre choix dans tous les cas mais en
tout cas cela n'a pas de lien avec sept
parties anatomiques du chlore qui
élimine tout ça à dire dans cette cette
fausse idée sauf aux liens entre hyménée
virginité c'est très anciens s'est
retrouvé dans plusieurs sociétés dans
plusieurs religions et c'est quand même
une vision assez patriarcale et
hétéronormée donc je vais m'expliquer
patriarcale pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit
quand même ici de contrôler le corps des
femmes de contrôler leur sexe de
contrôler leur sexualité et au delà de
contrôler leurs capacités reproductives
parce que c'est quand même de ça qu'il
s'agit
c'est que lorsque la femme reste vierge
pour le mariage si elle tombe enceinte
ce sera donc forcément de son mari et
non pas de quelqu'un d'autre
donc j'aime cette idée est par ailleurs
cette idée des terreaux normativité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que on ne conçoit les rapports sexuels
que comme un rapport hétérosexuel
potentiellement fécondant c'est-à-dire
un rapport sexuel de pénétration entre
un pénis et un vagin
or c'est une vision fausse ici aussi
associé rapports sexuels et pénétrations
ça n'a pas de sens il y a des
pénétrations dans le ve le vagin qui ne
sont pas des rapports sexuels par
exemple mettre un tampon ou une coupe
menstruelle peu
un petit peu dilater l'hymen et pourtant
ça n'a rien de sexuel et al'inverse des
des pratiques telles que le client ait
lieu sous la masturbation externes sont
réellement de la sexualité
tu t'impliques absolument aucune
pénétration donc voilà on va voir que en
fait ce lien entre iman et virginité non
seulement il faut anatomiquement mais en
plus intellectuellement c'est un petit
peu fumeux